well a new book wants us to put work
aside and actually start living it asked
why can't we just take a break the book
is called do nothing and author Celeste
Headley writes that we are working more
not less and we are living harder not
smarter
she also says we are now lonelier and
more anxious Headley writes quote we are
members of the cult of efficiency
Celeste Headley good morning good
morning welcome oh welcome I have to say
the book was a tough read for me because
as a person who loves to do something
every personality totally it just it
just drove me a little bit bit bit batty
I want to know what should we be doing
just slow down
well I mean there's a few things going
on here right it's really nuanced
obviously technology is a problem so one
of the first things you should be doing
is trying to take breaks from it but
technology isn't the source of the
problem so even if you were to toss your
cellphone into the river it wouldn't
solve your problem the culture that
emphasizes long hours and constant hard
work and constant efficiency and
improvement that's the source of the
problem that's a little harder to
counteract you're right that we every
time we open our email we are polluting
our time that's correct so we think okay
so let's say that you get a half hour
for lunch right and you go and you eat
your lunch and while you're eating your
lunch you're scanning through social
media or yes exactly
well your brain doesn't distinguish
between that and actual work yeah so you
have not taken a break in fact you're
going to get to the end of the day
completely exhausted because you've
given your brain and body frankly no
rest and they need that yeah so what do
you do then like the clock has been
invented right the Industrial Revolution
happened right we're all in a capitalist
economy time really is money in the way
we live how do you fight against all of
that as one person well I mean I
wouldn't fight necessarily fight against
it but what I would say is that you do
have 15 or 20 minutes here or there
right so if you actually get a little
bit of a break instead of searching
through Zappos for a new pair of boots
with your gift which again your brain
interprets as work okay walk outside you
can leave your cellphone at home or at
your desk for 15 minutes it's
okay you will survive just go take an
actual break so this is the real culprit
then so I imagine symptom it's making it
way easier for us to do things in a
toxic way that have been developing
since the late 19th century so where do
we find this healthy work-life balance I
mean that's gonna be ten depend on you
right your balance might be different
from mine but I will tell you that that
boundary between work and home needs to
be re-established right now we're doing
home things at work and we're doing a
lot of work things at home which means
to our brains and bodies our physiology
we're not ever taking a break we're
basically working all the time terms
right here like what what is leisure
time versus time off yeah interesting
because time off is basically the time
you're taking to sort of refresh
yourself to get back to work right
that's not actual leisure time I've read
all these articles telling you advising
you to leverage your vacation please
don't do that
please do not do that that's your
leisure time it should be time for you
to just chill that doesn't mean you're
idle right like a fisherman is working
while they're idle it doesn't mean
inactivity it just means that you're not
focused on producing something I love
that you have I believe this is a slot a
very happy looking slot they say but how
in a sense you we're fighting the
culture though right if we're when we're
trying to dial down like this we are and
how do you fight the culture well you
know that kind of depends on your power
right do you have the power to change
your schedule and and be in control of
your schedule great if you don't then
you're gonna have to end up taking those
15 20 minute breaks whenever you
possibly can and most importantly if you
sit down to watch a movie just watch the
movie increasingly difficult easy or
just read the book and none of this time
has come let's pick up her book that's
Celeste Hadley thank you so much my
pleasure do nothing is on sale tomorrow
so I tried to get it on on audiobooks
but couldn't well that would that would
encourage you to do